[Música]
a seta
ai galera que seu canal tudo com vocês
ela está falando nisso e o dvd desse ano
vai ter também de novo vai ter sim dvd
aqui pra vocês e do rio de janeiro foi
gravado jeneci arena já está vendendo
ingresso no primeiro link na descrição
do vídeo você quer do rio de janeiro que
participaram do dvd você quer de forma
mesmo assim cai por dvd que é se
programar a viagem para o rio de janeiro
primeiro link na descrição do vídeo é
nóis saúde spais a old spice ele chamou
o de aproveitar aqui eu poderei foi já
mandou odorante old spice cabra macho
que está lançando agora ele mandou dois
na cama e mandou dois vão gastar 1 que
nem aqueles caras de propaganda sempre
quis fazer isso assim sexy na propaganda
não tem fim
outra vez que vejo a propaganda e já
garantiu ficar olhando pra ficar lá meu
deus do céu eu aqui com o seu vácuo pôde
em casa e ficar gastando o garoto
inclusive até os amigos do vasco pôde
que eu tenho vontade de mandar ele para
propaganda dessa nova propaganda favor
faça propaganda durante mesmo que tudo
seja o ator ficou ali por perto pegar
rebarbas e no cheiro que está a melhorar
a menina tinha três foi a minha vida
três era só três sonho não era muita
coisa três só o primeiro era quebrar o
braço para botar hoje está nem escrever
e buscar água pra mim na escola me
cobrasse que é da casa tinha sar a
verificar com jesus passava era tempo
gesso eu tinha um amigo meu braço quebra
cujas ele jogar voleibol falando eu não
vou fazer sim a copa aqui e volto aqui
tá aqui coxa que vai do jardim bom para
quebrar o braço porque break é doido
adoro era um gesso que o gesso daquele
negócio tinha vontade no rg - ian
baterias aqui mas por favor não está
acabado se foi só uma luxação tá
quebrado esse rapaz do braço é meu se
quer saber marcar e eu que tenho o meu
próprio braço a segunda coisa era botar
aparelho carla tinha muita vontade de
papai noel desde que era um negócio dado
parece que sim eu tenho três irmãos
parece que o dente dos irmãos ailton
troca botar um bilhete - ou jogaram bem
da minha irmã pra mim o menor ou maior
de lado de frente onde decorre este
voltar botar parei porque eu sempre
estudei em escola pública sabe que a
escola pública não é não é com mais fora
dos ringues a escola dos riquinhos
seguir todo mundo é bonito todo mundo
tem a pele bonitinha o de tizi nasce
tudo no lugar de ti comportado e dente
de rodrigo ricco quando vai nascer ele
pede permissão ao dente de leite para
poder por favor poderia me conceder o
seu espaço ao debate lançou por favor
claro pode entrar em um lugar pois estou
demasiadamente usado ano vou me retirar
o que acontece cai tanto a inace outro
dentro do pop conversa não odeia de
leite natalie começa a ser falado manhã
em um acidente aqui em cima me fica com
49 dentro da boca parece um vampiro ou
seja que estuda em escola de rico quando
a pessoa vem botar aparelho até maria ho
e feio amb lusa agora na escola o qual
não excluo do pobre quando a pessoa vem
botar aparelho é porque tem condição
eita toda catarina ele é ela
uma boca desta manhã que não tem costume
de aparecer primeiro dia que eu sabia
que eu tinha um time botar aparelho na
escola pública até aquele estatuto está
ligado pela fumaça é a terceira coisa
ela tem bárbara não tenho barba não
adianta isso aqui ó
isso aqui é um cabelo de sovaco que deu
errado é de sovaco se eu fizer assim
acho graça eu sinta que eu tenho uns que
são pior que esses aqui um mês aqui ou
seja você consegue ver aí eu puxando ele
a gente não tem barba temos pela rússia
que nasce do nada não sei se eles
erraram como por exemplo isso aqui olha
olha o df pelo ver nascer
isso aqui é um perde com quem realizou
do gol até que ele foi crescendo
crescendo crescendo 1 saiu no peixe ao
pegar o cabelo com a bola e puxar um e
saques homem porque ele vai atacar
quando peguei com babados ego fica aqui
a minha né
enquanto o cabelo no peito ao tamanho
desse cabelo forte sedoso abandonar seu
redor do meu pai brincando de ciranda
cirandinha avó do meu pirão tirei
dinheiro vamos todo tirando vamos dar
meia-volta van e nem vai mudar ele
queria uma barba mas não nasci nenhum
jeito o cabelo era do cuiabá realizou
até no pé e às vezes se pensa o besteira
e falou de seu cabelo e barba quer ver
baiano é a barba e careca e na
adolescência essas coisas são
importantes em deus amigo que dite a
barra meus amigos e tinha cabelo silva
que não tinha cabelo escova adolescência
do menino era isso que era mas seus
primeiros cabelinho que já se sente o
chão o menino na escola aí a 10
ele é meu é o meu problema era esse
porque o primeiro cabelo que nasceu não
foi aqui no fundo do peito
não foi do bpp não foi de chuva por tuco
grande loft sedou é grande cascavel
balançou grande mostra 10 fazendo rapel
assim o bota me faz band ampla margem o
cabelo com no ps joga e volta agora
medindo como é que eu ia mostrar por
meus amigos
à saída do hotel não olha o teu cabelo
cua ió de cabelo a respeitar a rua não
tem gosto de fazer o negócio é só dormir
muito bem estou doido mas descobri que
isso não tem nada a ver cara barba não
tem nada a ver com ser cabra macho
aceitava mas tem que ter coragem você
tem que a atitude é perfeito a fazer os
cursos e não via nem ser homem para ser
capa mas falha minha mãe era mais cabra
macho que todos os machos minha família
um dia lá em casa com a mãe está
costurando e meu pai tava com 11 anos na
cozinha lá em casa assim tem negócio
graças a deus eu cresci em um ambiente
menos machista de todo mundo graças à
lei caso ela chegue sequer falei pra
você vai lá olha a minha mãe lavava
roupa meu pai fazer comida de meu pai é
lavar roupa manhã fazer comida em casa e
assim vai fazendo a comida pareceu
desabar até se machucar e casa meu aí
começou a rolar
[Música]
chegou uma mãe matou é e da bolsa
mamãe era mais calma mas que todo mundo
em casa acaba marcha atitude é perfeito
para fazer as coisa eu não tenho barba
mas acaba mais fácil fazer essa dança é
ridícula milhões de pessoas assistiram
os pais me fez o desafio tal desafio
cabra macho que vou gostar amanhã no meu
instagram é esse aqui ó a roubar ainda
som você que não saiu gol importante
desafio lá e vou desafiar outra pessoa
não só seguir nesta manhã e vê o desafio
para ver quem é a pessoa que vai
desafiar e ver qual é o desafio se você
gostou desse vídeo não se esqueça se
explicar e gostei já avisei no vídeo e
vou avisar de novo você não clique em
gostei e com o tempo vai parar de
receber o videoclipe mostrei aqui que
você comente aqui em baixo alguma coisa
que aconteceu quando você era criança e
que constrangeu muito natural licença
junto é nice
[Música]